don't think about anybody even don't
compare even if it's running don't
compare yourself to these people who are
doing hundreds of miles these fast pace
or these whatever
everybody has their own process their
own journey and if that's the goal
you'll get there just one day at a time
before i let you go
i think it would be good to uh kind of
pivot a little bit to talk about
um have a change
and and staying motivated you know what
you've done is so
inspirational and i feel like you do
such a good job
at communicating these ideas in a
relatable way so for the people that are
watching are listening
who are feeling inspired and
know they need to get off the couch and
do something it doesn't necessarily have
to be a run streak
but perhaps you know are in the process
of of rethinking their relationship to
their body and their selves and
and the trajectory that they're on in
life like how do you speak to that
person
i always say do something that's
pressure free and do something that's
attainable always those are the biggest
factors for me
and pressure free meaning don't do it
because
someone else is doing it do it because
you want to do it and do it on your own
timing
don't feel like you got to get it done
if it's a goal whatever you don't have
to get it done in 10 days
if you need a month a month is okay so
just do it pressure free
because because of that i fell in love
with running i never thought there was
no chance and now i get excited run and
i know running is tough
it has this brutal days but like i'm
still excited to go at it
so do it you don't feel the pressure of
maintaining the streak nope
zero pressure and i always say this too
this is how i feel about it
the day that i feel like it becomes more
of a pressure and i'm not liking it i'm
gonna stop
i'll stop and i don't know when that day
give yourself that permission yeah and
and i know i'll find something else i'll
find something else so
making sure it's not i don't have to go
i know i don't have to go run to keep a
street going
but i just do it because it feels good i
enjoy it and i want to keep sharing it
so
pressure free do it something that's
attainable and
just think about even spending five
minutes a day goes a long way
if it's something you love already or
you're thinking about you've been
thinking about that's
all the time to start doing it so if
diamond just spend five minutes of the
day
it's about volume five minutes a day for
seven days a week is going to add up
but if you just do it today and you take
a few days off that's not it
if you can do 10 minutes a day that's
also 10 minutes you can at least find
out of your day if it's important enough
to you
so as long as you want to do it and just
pressure free and get after it and don't
think about anybody even don't compare
even if it's running don't compare
yourself to these people who are
doing hundreds of miles these fast pace
or these whatever everybody has their
own process their own journey and if
that's the goal you'll get there just
one day at a time
i said i love it man yeah one day at a
time what about
somebody who's stuck in a job that they
feel like
isn't heading in the right direction
like you've done this pivot
yeah you've reinvented yourself from one
career to the next
um how do you think about you know
outside of running or fitness
making those kinds of pivots yeah so
there's two ways i
i i think them that may work that that
kind of worked for me so
when i was starting the run streak i was
actually working nine to five
and so just to not like a normal job i
wasn't
i was at a i was working at a place
called air brook it was a limousine
company
i was data entry because i used data but
it was a rental
car so i was there literally so training
i started training people aside
soccer speed and agility and soccer
technique and i was saying that that's
not guaranteed
i know the 40 whatever hours a week
money is guaranteed
but that one is the client cancellation
you your that week you might not get
money
but what i started looking at um doing
those hours
i said you know what sometimes you do a
little bit that you don't want to do
just to support your dreams
but making sure you're good with it
mentally if you're you don't if it's not
working for you mentally you got to
leave that environment so i literally
told myself this is for now and now you
see that you're not really this is not
good for you mentally because i
really didn't like it and i said leap of
faith quit the job
focus your energy on the soccer training
and
and i quit the job and that actually the
business literally
doubled after i put my energy into it
when i was scared of it so
it's one of those things when you're
stuck in a bubble right now it's just
the leap of faith
if you feel like you're stuck in a
bubble that's telling you everything
already
if you believe in god or the the
universe if you feel like you're stuck
that's the sign for you to make that
move and it may be scary and when i did
that i was very scared
because i'm thinking that training is
not guaranteed but the 9 if i was
guarantee a weekly money that i was
getting
but if you take the leap of faith that's
when you discover other things and then
when you know again
when you get put in uncomfortable
situation you'll find a way out
it might be brutal whatever you'll find
that next thing that's going to help you
sustain the life that you want to live
so just just take a leap of faith
i think that's what it is we're afraid
to fail be okay
to fail because it's not even failing
it's just a part of just
progressing and learning so i don't even
see failure as failure anymore
it's just that oh now i know what to do
better yeah i know what not to do so i
hate the word failure yeah
just take that leap of faith it's more
about having the courage to try
yeah that's exactly and it's the courage
actually that's the perfect word
because i had to have the courage to say
you know what i need to just stop this
and
go to the training and i was running on
the side and
also when something is not working for
you belle said this to me
she said to me and she said sometime you
are really stuck into something you want
it so bad it's not working out
but you have no idea is preparing you
for something better i think that was
perfectly for my story
i wanted soccer so bad i keep holding on
to it so tight and i didn't want to let
go but it was actually preparing me for
what i'm doing right now
well often when you're holding on too
tightly yeah you're
myopic to the greater opportunity you
can't see it because you're stuck
in a certain kind of pattern and there
is a mystical power to that idea
of the leap of faith because if you have
one foot in one world and one foot in
the next world
you're signaling to the universe that
you're not ready
yeah whatever the next thing is because
you're holding on to some
uh illusion of security that that
current situation or that
exact idea um represents for you
yes and it's only in the in the let
going of it that you provide the space
for the new thing to come in
yeah and you don't know how capable or
resilient you are
until you are sort of you know
chartering treacherous waters and your
back is up against the wall
and it's in that being tested that i
think you
allow yourself to come into you know a
greater capacity
exactly for potential can you write
another book that was really good
that was so that's literally that's
literally it
that's literally perfectly said honestly
that's hard though man yeah
you know and you gotta look at you and
i'm like i'm so much older than you i'm
like you're so young who cares like
you know take the risk what do you got
to lose man
back to work at work at the limousine
company yeah exactly worst case scenario
and and then also i like to this
thinking thinking mentality
i used to think oh plan b and like no
there's no plan b there's only plan a
for me
so plan a means if if i'm planning able
to
to do something and it's not working it
doesn't mean i'm going to quit to go to
i'm not reverting to another one i'm
just going to reroute because if you
have a
let me this is my fallback now now
you're kind of like
not going all out for that one thing you
want you're thinking oh if it doesn't
work
there's this thing also but if you just
say i'm going to make it work if it if
planning doesn't work just rewrap
take a different route and even the gps
thing i don't know if you've heard of
this but i've heard this somewhere i
don't know who has said it
if you're going somewhere you're on a
highway you miss the exit guess what the
gps does
it doesn't quit on you it re-routes it
might take you in the longer direction
but it routes so if plan isn't working
it doesn't mean it's not gonna work just
reroute there's maybe another loophole
that you gotta find to make it happen so
um and thinking also worst case scenario
you'll find
something will come you'll survive and
that's
everybody i speak to and even reading
books um even the likes of yourself you
can see this thing that you know that
everything that you guys have did not
come
overnight you worked on it how you
change your lifestyle
but people see what you're able to do
right now it's very amazing it's very
all but do they realize you had to go
through so much
you have to literally go through all
these process to get to where you're at
so we also have to think that we see
everybody on top of what they're doing
right now and it's amazing
but they had to start somewhere so it's
okay if
i'm still trying to figure it out till
this day yeah in a they call it
you can't translate something you
haven't got yeah you have to burn in the
fire right you have to
emerge from some experience whether it
be a hardship
or whatever to carry a certain residence
that magnetizes other people so when i
look at you
your story what you've accomplished um
i appreciate that it didn't happen
overnight thank you you've been doing
this right
1500 days of running in a row like you
put in a lot of work
and you strike me as somebody who's
very um self-actualized or integrated
like i don't know
whether you've been to therapy but you
you whatever demons you may
or may not have like you've dealt with
them yeah and you're able to
um you know stand in your strength in a
certain way
thank you and there's something about
the positivity that flows outward from
you
that isn't just a guiding force for
yourself
it's very attractive to other people
people see that a lot of people have run
across the country right but
there's something about your experience
doing it and the way that you shared it
and the spirit with which
you carried yourself throughout this
experience that make people want to know
more they want to know more about you
and that attracts
casey to your front yard or all these
things that are coming to you
thank you and that doesn't happen by
happenstance that happens because you've
put in a tremendous amount of work and
you're very intentional in the way that
you're
you know approaching these things and
it's very commendable
the way that you're like i think i mean
it's cool that you ran across the
country it's cool that you've run
you know 1500 days in a row but when i
look at you like i want to sit down
across from you because i just like your
spirit and
thank you so much you're all about it
that means a lot yeah and i think
that there's so much more that you're
going to be contributing and offering
i appreciate that
[Music]
[Music]
you